[Music]
now the bellagio conservatory has
seasonal celebrations from all around
the world in one place
that's rival rocky theaters is showing
us around for the spring
so it looks like we're in washington d.c
right behind us at the famous cherry
blossom festival but no we are here at
the bellagio conservatory
here with ed and leslie the team behind
this beautiful place every single season
you bring us so much beauty and joy
thank you so let's start with the
storytelling ed you're the designer here
take us around the world where are we
going so we're not traveling in plains
right now for the most part so we're
traveling into the bellagio we're seeing
the whole world and the flower festivals
that are happening at this time of year
around the world
all right here at home at bellagio so
take us what locations we can visit
so we're here in washington dc at the
cherry blossom festival which is
absolutely magnificent
then we have this beautiful voyage to
thailand
here the sangprom which is a water
festival in thailand the
blessing of the buddha for the new year
which i think is just spectacular this
is very near and dear to my heart
we go from there to one of the most
famous flower festivals in the world
which is the chelsea flower show in
england with these beautiful
hummingbirds and beautiful there's going
to be butterflies in that in that uh in
that conservatory
so that's a conservative when do the
butterflies come out tomorrow i think
leslie's managing that whole thing okay
and then we go from we go from
from from england all the way over to
holland
and the kookanov which is the flower
festival that's held all across
all across holland which is kind of
amazing incredible and
way better than expensive flights okay
um they right here at bellagio
exactly with beautiful rooms and suites
so let's talk about the details that
went into designing this one in
particular
let's have leslie talk a little bit
about some of the processes that we use
which are kind of amazing uh-oh
i think he just challenged you i think
he wants you to drop some numbers
let's talk numbers then how many flowers
did you use for this display
so over this show we'll use over 30 000
live plants for the display
featuring our dutch bulb plants which
have been
contract grown for us they've been in
the ground waiting to reveal themselves
for the last year so we have hyacinth
daffodils and many different colors of
tulips and they smell so good
so good this is so because this is
spring obviously spring is about flowers
do you guys get a little more excited
for the spring display
we do because there's such renewal um
you know there's
there's uh such a burst of color and
fragrance that mother nature puts forth
for us all to enjoy absolutely and
speaking of bursts
there are there's a burst of people here
as well because things are loosening up
a little bit
so how is the conservatory capacity
change and
how's the crowd the crowd is wonderful
as always
the capacity hasn't really changed we're
still limiting
um the the access for people
and then also we're doing our our
uni-directional walk so that it's more
of an intimate experience
beautiful okay coming up later in the
show we're gonna talk more to ed about
the details and the story behind each
festival you guys can visit
not around the world but here at the
bellagio we'll see you later
it's so pretty you know it smells so
good in there christian and it's amazing
how quickly they do the turnover from
one display to the next but that
hummingbird
one that looks amazing i know that's so
beautiful and then of course i'm a
little partial to the dutch one with the
tulips and the windmill because
true or false that's where i was born
okay uh
true very good very very good you got it
all right